il
[Musique]
alors maintenant imaginez un cocktail
sac et qu'elle pérignat ou encore un
personnage de manga puis dans la
capoeira allez savoir pourquoi mais on
va tenter de vous l'expliquer on est là
pour ça le brésil et pays qui accueille
le plus de japonais et ils sont ici chez
eux pour les appels émis cei n'est ni
pau brasileiros êtes exactement 791 à
descendre du bateau le 18 juin 1908 ils
sont maintenant un million cinq cent
mille dans le pays dans la plupart ici à
sao paulo l'appel du 18 juin c'est un
sujet de michael burdell
ne soyez pas surpris si vous entendez
par les japonais dans les rues de sao
paulo dès 1908 165 fans foulent le sol
brésilien pour venir travailler dans les
plantations de café
depuis la communauté n'a cessé de se
développer pour compter près d'un siècle
plus tard un million et demi de membres
soit la plus importante communauté hors
japon au monde
c'est à libertad le quartier nippon de
sao paulo que l'on retrouve
principalement les [ __ ] les
descendants de japonais
dans son dojo sensei mariama comprenez
professeur mariama est arrivé d'okinawa
ya 25 ans ceinture noire 7e dan il
enseigne aujourd'hui le karaté à des
jeunes nippo brésilien
et cio au bon moi c'est une obligation
d'entretenir la culture nippone
c'est pas tout d'avoir une aide
japonaise il faut avoir l'esprit aussi
l'esprit samouraï il faut également le
transmettre aux descendants de japonais
honey pot brésiliens ni blasé lèvres
au fil du temps la communauté japonaise
s'est totalement intégré au point
qu'elle en a même perdu un peu de son
identité
reste en position basse
à c
quand j'étais môme les gens disaient à
regarde le japonais ça aujourd'hui ça a
changé la communauté japonaise de sao
paulo est l'une des plus anciennes de
ici cinq générations de japonais se sont
fondus dans l'une des villes les plus
cosmopolites du monde même au brésil
l'intégration est un concept qui prend
son temps à peine le temps d'ôter son
kimono que monsieur moriame à nous fait
découvrir libertad en bon nippon il
connaît le quartier comme sa poche un
petit bout du japon en plein coeur de
sao paulo ça c'est mon vieil ami il est
dans le quartier depuis très longtemps
malgré son importance la communauté
japonaise du brésil demeure méconnue au
pays du soleil levant
les japonais ne connaissent pas le
brésil japonais il pense qu'ici c'est
l'amazonie qu'est le football amateur la
samba et le cannibalisme
qu'il ya beaucoup de japonais qui sont
en lice la poney
[Musique]
regardez par ici ce sont des amis à moi
ok quand le packard bell elle coupe les
cheveux et elles sont japonaises ça fait
très longtemps qu'elles sont dans le
quartier ici sont très célèbres c'est
dans ce salon de coiffure que monsieur
hulot passé après midi ce retraité de 81
ans est le doyen du quartier il est
arrivé au brésil à l'âge de 4 ans ses
parents sont venus cueillir le café
[Musique]
les premiers immigrés étaient considérés
comme des esclaves
d'ailleurs les immigrants japonais sont
venus pour les remplacer après
l'abolition de l'esclavagé
le patron de la plantation nous et c'est
à partir il fallait fuir et il allait
même jusqu'à tuer les gens
en un siècle les japonais ont connu des
périodes sombres brésil l'esclavagisme
donc au début du 20e siècle puis la
seconde guerre mondiale quand leur pays
d'accueil a déclaré la guerre à leur
pays donné 110 élèves et ici ils vendent
des livres japonais c'est la seule
librairie vraiment authentique
persécutés pendant la guerre la langue
et les manifestations culturelles
japonaises sont interdites impossible
alors d'exprimer son identité
durant la seconde guerre mondiale le
gouvernement a confisqué et à brûler
tous les livres écrits en japonais
font d'abord le fondateur de cette
librairie à récupérer après la guerre
les vieux livres qui restaient
il a commencé à les vendre et tout le
monde a voulu les acheter
aujourd'hui cette librairie est
incontournable livres anciens manga et
revues de mode et des couvertures de
magazines à la réalité il n'ya qu'un pas
qu'a qu'emi franchi tous les jours cette
japonaise de 28 ans a popularisé la mode
lolita celle qui fait aussi fureur à
tokyo est super jolie je peux vous
prendre une photo tous ensemble
bien sûr
je les trouve très jolie c'est une
culture différente et c'est cool ça
égaye notre
[Musique]
c'est too much pour moi mais c'est
vilain
akemi est arrivé au brésil à l'âge de 19
ans six ans plus tard elle se lancer
dans la mode lolita avec une toute
petite ambition changer le monde
le monde est plein de problèmes
deux choses - chant oui deux crimes
hiver des l'unita va changer tout ça va
apporter plus de bonheur plus de paix de
glamour et d'amour et c'est ça
l'essentiel
akemi enseigne le japonais avec une
méthode pédagogique unique au monde le
karaoké
aujourd'hui cinq élèves attention vous
rentrez dans une salle de classe
son origine si aucune eau
[Musique]
aline west ham wayne ti depuis l'arrivée
des japonais il ya un siècle la langue
originelle est devenu obsolète moi
j'apporte quelque chose de nouveau c'est
pour ça que mes cours ont beaucoup de
succès
mabille seulement à la mode japonaise je
dessine des mangas et maintenant
j'apprends les japonais je suis vraiment
né dans le mauvais pied j'aurais
vraiment dû naître au jeu c'est
[Musique]
nantes a des bons jeux mais dition
disent bravo à tout c'était super
j'ai presque plus fort
akemi et le japon c'est une histoire
d'amour cet après midi on la retrouve à
la 12ème édition du salon annuel manga
de sao paulo tous les fans de la
japonisation sont réunis attention tout
nu correcte exigée
[Musique]
pour rien au monde à kevin aurait manqué
cet événement dont elle est l'une des
stars
je reviens à quelle heure pour chanter
alors que tu veux ça commence à 18h30 il
ya toujours du retard
brésil champion des noms de famille
japonais non plus l'apparence japonaise
a parlé c'est du japonais ce domaine
regardez moi je n'ai pas l'air japonaise
et j'ai pourtant des origines
[Musique]
comme attila à sao paulo 6 ans minuit
pour brésiliens vivent pleinement leur
culture nippone impossible dès lors d'
identifier en raison des métissages les
[ __ ] les descendants nippon dans les
coulisses la pression monte d'un cran
avant de monter sur scène
je commence à être un peu nerveuse
[Musique]
succès et merde à tour son bâton cassé
[Applaudissements]
bernier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour akemi le pari est réussi dans six
mois lors du prochain salon elle
reviendra enflammé les planches
désormais grâce à elle et ses disciples
la mode japonaise est plus que jamais
vivante à sao paulo mieux encore la
jeunesse nippo brésilienne a remis sur
les rails une culture nippone en
perdition depuis des années
[Musique]
la grèce est devenue le symbole de la
crise européenne ce qui évite à
l'espagne d'être trop exposés car allez
savoir pourquoi on n'a pas toujours
l'impression d'avoir bien pris la mesure
de la crise espagnole peut-être parce
qu'ils sont bons scores et les médailles
récoltées il pourrait bien finir par les
cartons et les revendre rendez vous
compte 800 mille espagnols ont quitté le
pays pour tenter leur chance ailleurs
notamment ici à sao paulo et vous allez
voir le miracle brésilien ça marche pas
à tous les coups on l'a vu avec les
boliviens mais ici ça a changé leur vie
les nouveaux conquistadors c'est un
sujet de pierrick morel
non très douce
ajout 33 ans
nationalité espagnole
profession peintre décorateur à chaque
chantier c'est pareil 13 août doit
décliner son identité arrivé il ya huit
mois sao paulo il découvre les joies de
la sécurité ici ses riches clients se
barricadent incident la moitié des
immeubles c'est comme si tu habitais à
guantanamo
forteresse doré ou pas la grande
différence entre l'espagne et le brésil
c'est qu'ils s'y résout c'est du boulot
et un nouveau bleu de travail
pour bosser porté les couleurs du brésil
c'est normal et
d'autant plus normal que résout ce doigt
au brésil sa résurrection en espagne il
vivait heureux jusqu'à ce que la crise
économique le flanque au chômage en 2007
là bas j'en étais au coin je ne pouvais
plus payer l'essence de la voiture la
situation de l'emploi était désastreuse
je suis arrivé ici avec mon épouse j'ai
commencé à travailler dès le premier
jour
ici il ya du boulot à gogo ruiner en
espagne ici résoud gagne sa croûte est
plutôt bien même 3000 real par mois près
de 1200 euros c'est 5 fois le salaire
minimum au brésil
et si ma vie a beaucoup changé du tout
au tout en mieux bien sûr
résoudre c'est l'énergie de la jeunesse
perdue pour l'espagne aujourd'hui le
pays est laminée par le chômage plus de
40 % chez les moins de 35 ans du coup
beaucoup sont poussés à l'exil un
chiffre clé en 2011 800 mille d'entre
eux ont quitté le pays les espagnols qui
croyait en avoir fini avec les grandes
migrations ont dû se faire une raison
les parents ont émigré en allemagne
quand j'étais jeune à l'époque de franco
sanitaire assure la continuité de la
famille
en traversant l'atlantique l'horizon de
résoudre s'est brusquement dégagé il
faut dire qu'il a atterri dans le plus
grand aspirateur de main d'oeuvre
d'amérique latine grande industrie
sièges sociaux de multinationales sao
paulo pèse pour 30% du pib brésilien
dans un tel chaudron 1 travailleurs
qualifiés venus d'europe a un boulevard
devant lui
la réussite de résultats de quoi
susciter des vocations
cette semaine il a fait le tour de la
ville avec son ami de toujours marcos
nos deux ibères nourrissent le projet de
monter une affaire ensemble marcos est
venue de séville pour prospecter
salue tout va bien tu appelles celio
lui c'est marcos et moi c'est jesús 13
ou c'est marcos multiplie les rendez
vous avec les agents immobiliers
objectif trouver un local bien situé en
vue d'ouvrir un bar restaurant
c'est combien pour ce local ces 2000
real par mois
ça fait environ 800 euros
marcos poste dans une cristallerie à
séville pour l'instant il a été épargné
par la crise
mais lui et résout sont amis à la mort
et les visions de grandeur brésilienne
de son pote lui ont filé le virus de
l'entrepreneur
je vois que pour mon pote ça marche ici
il gagne sa vie
il ya beaucoup d'options pour monter une
affaire moi j'aimerais monter un truc
avec lui et l'aider à grandir
c'est un pays en pleine croissance il
faut en profiter
il faut en profiter maintenant parce
qu'on est dans une très bonne période
marcos et résoudre s'ils voient déjà et
il compte bien user de leurs
spécificités nationales pour conquérir
un brésil ouvert à toutes les influences
une paella tu l'as fait ici une paella
espagnol une tortilla ou si l'on fait de
la paella jusqu'à notre premier client
on va faire plein de poils à différents
[Musique]
les vieux équilibres mondiaux bascule
les économies du sud dame le pion à
celle du nord et attire des
conquistadors d'un genre nouveau sao
paulo ces nouveaux riches et ces
nouvelles boutiques de luxe dans la
mégapole le haut du pavé est à 2 rue des
bas quartiers ceux des ateliers de
confection et des grossistes
c'est ici la face cachée du monde de la
mode
ici que yann irait jeune styliste
espagnole a posé ses valises
j'adore cet endroit je suis fan des
boutons des rubans vraiment tous ses
accessoires j'adore
au milieu de tous ces accessoires y
admirer a les yeux d'une petite fille
habillant sa poupée mais ian ayre ne
joue pas et les chefs d'entreprise et
c'est beaucoup plus terre-à-terre
il faut être ici pour produire là-bas en
espagne y'a pas moyen d'être compétitif
m vous savez on a beaucoup de clients du
monde entier
les coûts de production la compétitivité
voilà ce qui a poussé yann irait à
quitter l'espagne pour créer à sao paulo
sa propre marque de vêtements elle
fabrique ses collections dans un atelier
du quartier
[Musique]
là c'est la salle principale il ya
l'étape de modelage c'est là qu'on est
content
nous verrons ça c'est un modèle que j'ai
créée pour la collection d'été 1 qui
s'est finalement transformé en robe de
mariée
il ya n'irait fait presque du sur mesure
et en très petite quantité plus jeune
elle rêvait de londres ou de paris mais
elle a très vite compris que le meilleur
moyen de se faire un nom en europe c'est
de s'expatrier car aussi paradoxal que
cela puisse paraître yanni rêvons
l'essentiel de sa collection non pas au
brésil mais chez elle pour pays basque
espagnol
la plupart des nouveaux stylistes et
toutes les grandes marques s'en vont en
chine
le brésil c'est la nouvelle chine la
nouvelle inde
pour moi aujourd'hui c'est la seule
façon viable pour que mes produits
soient vendus dans les boutiques
espagnol
y admirer n'est pas la seul espagnol à
avoir eu l'idée de s'implanter au brésil
entre 2009 et 2010 le nombre
d'entreprises ibérique cherchant à
s'installer ici est passé de 80 à 2000
pour devenir patronne de sa marque ian
ayre n'avait pas d'autre choix que de
partir en quête de bas salaires
ici je vois les gens dans le besoin la
pauvreté
c'est très dur et j'ai du mal ensuite à
apporter mes modèles dans les boutiques
chic alors qu'il ya de la misère tout
autour
sam est vraiment difficile
bien lire est une enfant de la
globalisation mais la voix qu'elle
emprunte écorche ses propres convictions
elle nous emmène chez les indignés un
mouvement de contestation globale n'est
chez elle en espagne au printemps 2011
même dans un brésil en pleine croissance
le modèle économique est remis en cause
c'est un peu lié avec de nombreuses
opportunités à l'est aussi avec ses
problèmes
ici au brésil il ya un boom économique
mais il profite qu'à peu de gens
riches s'enrichissent et les pauvres
genk très peu
pour vous admirez le brésil c'est votre
eldorado
eldorado c'est a des connotations
négatives liées à l'exploitation le fait
d'arriver 2,3 et de partir
il ya n'irait projette pourtant de
repartir un jour en espagne car la
bassée création commence à être reconnu
et admiré une jeune patronne qui navigue
entre idéaux et ambition
sur la pao liste à la 5e avenue locale
il y a les indignés et à l'autre bout au
même moment réseau c'est marcos qui se
disent au revoir et surtout à bientôt
marcos s'en va demain mais il compte
bien revenir très vite
à kenneth rogoff si tu as une maison
mais que tu sais la porte est grande
ouverte au monde et au brésil la même
veine d'eau
quand même tu sais salud les deux
compagnies rostren qu'à leur amitié à
leurs projets au brésil et au goût de la
vie retrouvée par crésus
dépression en espagne il faisait une
dépression il est physiquement malade
vous savez dans sa sphère sa tournée
sans cesse il avait les nerfs à vif
et maintenant je vois qu'il est bien
négociée il a des projets il va être
papa il a du travail il a de l'argent et
les neuvicois
certes sa famille les potes le pays lui
manque mais à sao paolo fresu sa chasser
ses démons il semblerait que le nouveau
monde donne des ailes à des espagnols
plombé par la crise c'est certain de
madrid à sao paulo le prochain vol de
nuit viendra gonfler les rangs de la
communauté hispanique
[Musique]
c'est ici que tout a commencé là à mes
pieds c'est ici que la ville de sao
paulo a été fondé et c'est ici qu'on va
terminer pour aujourd'hui les paroles ne
salent pas la soupe at on l'habitude de
dire dans les rues de sao paulo alors je
vais pas m'étaler mais j'espère que vous
avez apprécié le voyage en tous les cas
nous ici on a senti quelque chose cette
ville n'est pas comme les autres et nous
bien sûr on va se retrouver très vite
sur d'autres routes et sur planète pour
un autre autour du monde de l'actualité
internationale avec un ticket de métro à
bientôt raté à logo
[Musique]